antes mas muito bom dia a todos agradeço
o convite
o convite eu vou contar uma história se
tiver de ser muito chata
ok é de não dizer nada e turma potter é
uma vez de uma menina que a vivência de
maneira feira em um dia alguns técnicos
da câmera
santa maria da feira dirigiram à escola
dela para apresentar um projeto que se
chamava jovem ataca uma espécie de
presidente da câmara dos jovens
inscritos no evento jovem autarca tinha
ter entre 13 e 16 anos
além deles tinha também de apresentar um
manifesto com três propostas
tinha também khan recolher pelo menos 50
assinaturas
olha bem uma menina civil caminha tas
com juntamente com o apoio dos amigos o
que fez na campanha seria distribuir
vários panfletos cria uma página no
facebook e promover o imenso o vídeo que
fez para para para a campanha não via
nem tomar posse ela não sabia eu
esperava e surpreendentemente só quero a
vencedora ela ficou muito emocionada ela
e que deverá chegar no ct mas está muito
bonito e ganhou a etapa agora é
trabalhar
bora lá pessoal ela não estava sozinha
não é trabalhar sozinha é a equipa é
constituída por ela e pelos restantes
candidatos a ganhar ataca e eu tenho
reuniões de 15 em 15 dias
no entanto a jovem à toca não tinha só
essas reuniões têm e também reuniões com
várias entidades que em reuniões também
com com os vereadores foram os primeiro
e segundo volante e assim foram
começando a estratégia é um dos
primeiros projetos foi a atribuição de
bolsas de mérito aos melhores alunos de
cada ano
sim mas com dário queda escolas do
concelho outro projeto foi a um workshop
de orientação vocacional realizam duas
vezes e foi também o início da
construção do projeto no skate park
kan ainda hoje está a correr bem estou
tudo isso tem as suas dificuldades e uma
das principais dificuldades sentidas
pela menina foi o fato de ter dirigido
uma equipa de cerca de 20 dólares
é muito fácil nós temos opiniões
diferentes e qual é que é opinião mais
valia não existem opiniões mais vale nas
somos todos iguais temos que cheguei a
ouvir uns aos outros não podemos
valorizar ninguém como é muito
ela achou que era muito difícil gerir
isto no entanto estas dificuldades foram
ultrapassados e à equipa porque ninguém
trabalha sozinho eo projeto seguiu este
ano continuar existe uma nova jovem
autarca foi convidada pela unicef a
fazer parte dos mundiais
mas a união européia está representado e
por isso a minha fez parte da equipa da
união européia foi não via a trabalhar
com todo mundo conhecer todos os países
tinham vários grupos ligados a grupos
ligados ao empoderamento das mulheres
grupos ligados ao epp ao projovem e
também existe um grupo chamado comércio
justo e foi exatamente o grupo que
entrou
o passado chega de setores se postando
trabalharem os jovens criaram position
paper que entregaram a chanceler não né
a menina virou com o fora o facto de ter
fome quando podia por escolher a voz é a
língua que podia ouvir havia português
também teve que ouvir em inglês porque
havia tradução simultânea estuprar a
jovem só vocês querem sua vitória dessas
coisas mas para jovens que nunca tiveram
a oportunidade de estar numa conferência
assim foi espetacular
depois destas destes nove dias
a minha opção por trazer várias
vanguarda do conhecimento se pode
acrescentar valor ao trabalho que estava
a fazer essa briga foi estranho a menina
vai voltar a estar em belém novamente
porque os jovens foram todos convidados
pelo governo uma estarem novamente lá
para continuarem a trabalhar essa minha
sou eu chamo esf tem 26 anos e estou sim
a história caminha em santa maria da
feira
espero que a vida é feita de escolhas
explica nenê mas agora vou seguir
adiante é possível a espero continuar a
envolver em por gente
hoje provavelmente não estaria aqui
o documento deste lado do estado ela não
estaria aqui a falar sobre este projecto
não se tivesse candidatado senão que vai
se arriscar e se não tivesse uma tela do
fato não iria também amanhã não teria
foi de project como fiz por isso deixar
uma mensagem que é à risca faca faça
alguma coisa seja às vezes o clima feita
mas é jovem e voltem a fazer tv que um
dia vai acabar nunca se esqueçam de onde
vêm e vossa identidade e um de vocês
pertencem
por exemplo se você já ouviu falar da
viagem medieval
essa tônica foi resista viagem medieval
que decorre de 27 de julho e 7 de agosto
são dois dias eu vou a berlim 2 e 5 de
agosto
eu não criei na liga o rio porque assim
a viagem revela eu adoro a viagem deu a
sugestão é que eu vou fazer
graças a deus que eu vou preferir os
primeiros seis dias da viagem minha avó
e depois vou dizer para mim por tudo é
possível e tudo fácil às vezes filmes é
fazer escolhas
essas escolhas panem grãos mas no final
eu tenho a certeza de uma coisa tudo vai
dar certo em um dia muito provavelmente
vocês não estejam lá é da amg lamento
muito eu acho que ela é obrigada